Ezra Bridger has finally made
his long-awaited return to the
Star Wars franchise — but did you
recognize the actor who plays him?
Star Wars fans had a lot to get excited about
going into the Disney+ series Ahsoka. Not only
was Ahsoka Tano about to get a live-action project
of her own after over a decade in animation,
but the series was to mark the live-action
debut of beloved Rebels characters. As the
series unfolded, the likes of Hera
Syndulla and Sabine Wren took the
spotlight. While it's been great to see
these animated favorites in live-action,
fans have continued to ask the big
question: where's Ezra Bridger?
Ezra last appeared in the Rebels finale,
in which a pod of purrgil take him and Grand
Admiral Thrawn out of the known galaxy,
leaving Sabine and the rest of his friends behind.
Years after his disappearance, Sabine travels to
a distant world in the hopes of finding him
— and sure enough, Ezra is alive and well.
"I can't wait to go home."
For Ahsoka, actor Eman Esfandi takes over
from Rebels voice actor Taylor Gray. It's
entirely possible that you've seen Esfandi
before — though it's not all that likely.
This is because, with Ahsoka, he is adding a
major credit to his rather short filmography.
Unlike many of the actors on Ahsoka, who
boast robust acting résumés that go back
decades and span screens big and small,
Eman Esfandi is only just starting out in
the industry. His earliest credit is from 2017
in the form of the short film FU Glory Days,
in which he takes on the role of Hammer.
His filmography is largely populated by
more short films from subsequent years,
such as 2018's Why We Fight and 2019's I
Am Mackenzie, although Esfandi does have some
feature-length efforts to his name as well.
Esfandi scored his first feature
film credit in 2018's Red 11,
which was directed by none other than Robert
Rodriguez, who also directed episodes of The
Mandalorian and Book of Boba Fett. Esfandi
later took roles in Phaedra, Austin Weird,
and the Will Smith-led King Richard. Right
now, the most recent silver screen production
under Esfandi's belt was 2022's The Inspection —
though it stands to reason that his body of work,
acting talent, and exposure from Ahsoka will
bring him more roles in the near future.
Notably, Esfandi has done a superb
job filling very big shoes — and
under difficult circumstances. If there's one
thing the Star Wars fandom has become known
for over the years, it's a reluctance
and occasional hostility toward change.
“Wow, you’re about as bright
as a binary droid. They’re
not going to come for me. People don’t do that.”
So, when the news broke that Eman Esfandi
was on the hook to take the baton from
Taylor Gray as Ezra Bridger, some online
fans naturally pushed back. Of course,
while fans in certain corners of the Internet
voiced their displeasure at this new casting,
most folks were excited to see where Esfandi's
take on the character was headed. In fact,
before the series even released, fans expressed
a great deal of support for his casting.
Back in December 2022, a Redditor posted
an interview with Esfandi in which he had
been asked about his casting as Ezra
in Ahsoka. In the comment section,
Star Wars fans were blown away
by how perfectly cast he was,
with his voice standing out as a solid match
for an aged-up version of the character.
“That’s the Idea”
In another thread, fans were amazed by
how much Esfandi looks like the animated
version of Ezra and discussed how they couldn't
wait to see him suit up on the small screen.
So far, both Esfandi and the live-action version
of Ezra appear to be a hit. And we'll no doubt
see more of this version of the character
as Ahsoka's first season draws to a close.